what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
really exciting news as disney has
announced their date for disney plus day
and if you're familiar at all with
disney plus day we usually get a lot of
big reveals so phase 5 is about to be
revealed we're going to talk about what
we already know and what we expect to be
released except this year we're actually
in for a little bit more than normal
because disney plus day is taking place
one day right before d23 so september is
actually going to bring us a ton of new
marvel star wars everything else that
comes with disney plus a ton of new
reveals here which is really exciting
because i know a lot of people are
really really wondering what exactly the
future of the mcu holds and i will say
the mcu does look bright i think it's
about to get a lot brighter star wars
actually looks extremely bright and i
will be doing a watch party for obi-wan
tonight that'll start at 11 30 pacific
time and if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news and so you can
help us get to 1 million subscribers now
typically between disney plus day and
d23 we always get a ton of information
and a lot of new reveals disney always
takes this opportunity at these two
events to tease us with what's to come
in the future in fact between these two
events over the past couple of years
since san diego comic-con didn't happen
this is where disney and marvel did all
of their biggest reveals this is where
they talked about the fantastic four
being in development this is where they
revealed all the shows like armor wars
iron heart secret invasion released
teaser trailers for the first time that
we never saw before so be rest assured
that these are big events that you don't
want to miss out on and of course if
you're subscribed to the channel i'll be
doing updates on these so no worries now
right away here's what is really
exciting for marvel fans we have a few
marvel release dates that are set they
are lined up disney is planning on
releasing movies during these dates but
they don't have set movies yet meaning
they have publicly released the release
dates but they don't have a movie
attached to the release dates so we
don't know what's being released but
hopefully at d23 or disney plus day
they're going to tell us what movies are
coming out on these dates with the
biggest hope right now it's my personal
hope and a lot of the fans personal hope
that we actually get a release date for
fantastic four and maybe even a smidgen
of info about the cast now in regards to
the fantastic four recent reports have
told us that john watts is no longer the
director so maybe they'll give us a
director announcement also spoiler alert
if you have not seen doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness maybe they'll
actually confirm that john krasinski is
going to be playing the main mcu reed
richard slash mr fantastic in the
upcoming movie and if they did announce
that he is indeed going to be playing
that role as well hopefully they would
announce that his wife would be playing
sue storm slash the invisible woman if
she is indeed going to be playing that
role remember this is where the big
announcements happened they actually
revealed that jonathan mages was going
to be playing kang and that kang was
coming to the mcu during these events so
this is where this stuff takes place
these are huge events now keep in mind
though disney plus day is not going to
announce anything about movies why well
because it's in the title it's disney
plus day disney plus is not movies it's
shows now as far as marvel shows coming
to disney plus here's what we have we
have miss marvel which is about to come
out we have she-hulk attorney at law
that is coming out on august 17th we
have an untitled halloween special which
is widely believed to be werewolf by
night coming out obviously october since
it's for halloween and that is october
of this year 2022 then we have the
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
which is believed to be coming out in
december then we have the new x-men
animated series x-men 97 which i am very
very excited for we also have secret
invasion coming which does not have a
release date yet so i'm assuming the
possibilities for us getting a release
date for secret invasion on disney plus
day is pretty high then we have other
disney plus shows that have yet to get
release dates and those are i am groot
armor wars iron heart echo then of
course there are wakanda series coming
to disney plus we don't have release
dates for those yet either loki season 2
which is about to start filming we have
what if season 2 which is apparently
supposed to come this year in 2022 we
have the agatha harkness show that has
been announced that is titled agatha
house of harkness then we have the
spider-man freshman year show we have
marvel zombies and the big one which
hopefully we get an official
announcement from disney themselves is
the daredevil series coming to disney
plus now this one i do hope we get a
little bit of information on because i
know a lot of people are really worried
about the daredevil series being on
disney plus since the daredevil show on
netflix was pretty brutal fans are
concerned and worried and rightfully so
that it's gonna be toned down a lot
because this show is going to be on
disney plus however moon knight kind of
pushed it it wasn't exactly up there
with daredevil from netflix but it kind
of pushed it for a disney plus show so
hopefully if it's at least at that tone
it won't be too bad but i'm hoping and
fingers crossed that we do get a little
bit of information about this show now
that's all that can happen on disney
plus day getting information about those
disney plush shows because again disney
plus day it's all about disney plus but
d23 could bring some major reveals for
movies and here's all the movies that we
have coming up obviously thor love and
thunder is coming out july 8th that's
the next movie that is coming in the mcu
then we have black panther wakanda
forever which is currently scheduled for
november 11th of 2022. then we have
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania
february 17th of 2023 i'm really excited
to learn a little bit more about this
one because king the conqueror is going
to be introduced in this film then we
have guardians of the galaxy volume 3
which is scheduled for may 5th 2023
followed by the marvels coming july 28th
of 2023 now here's where this event
could get very interesting with all of
these announced films that don't have
release dates yet here's what we have
coming up that hopefully we get a little
bit more information about now just to
address spider-man for a second we
typically don't get any spider-man news
from disney directly it typically comes
from sony so i wouldn't expect too much
about the new spider-man movies but we
do have blade coming up along with
deadpool 3 the fantastic four movie
which again hopefully we get some
information about that and the cast
captain america 4 which is confirmed to
be happening but we don't really know
anything about it yet then there's
shangshi and the legend of the tin rings
2 which that has been announced but
little to no information is known about
it and then of course the big ones
hopefully we get an announcement for the
x-men especially and again spoiler alert
for doctor strange 2 since they showed
us professor xavier and multiverse of
madness now last year they announced the
fantastic four film and all they really
told us was that john watts was going to
be the director and that it was in
development so i'll take pretty much
anything if it's related to the x-men i
just simply want kevin feige to say hey
it's in development because the last
time we heard anything about the x-men
slash mutants was at san diego comic-con
of 2019 where he said we didn't even
have time to talk about the fantastic
four and the mutants now since he said
those two together and the fantastic
four is coming relatively soon hopefully
that means x-men isn't too far behind
and of course if we're really hoping for
something i don't think we'll get much
information about it but i would love to
hear anything about a new avengers film
little to no information is really known
about the new avengers team we actually
know more about the young avengers than
we do the new avengers so i'm hoping for
just anything about a new avengers team
and that's what's in store for these two
big events coming up it's very exciting
because we haven't had any major reveals
coming straight from disney in a pretty
long time so mark the calendar for these
events september 8th for disney plus day
and september 9th starts d23 and of
course i will be covering both events
extensively so be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
news don't forget to give the video a
like and of course for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof